aujourd'hui c'est jour de la sortie de
ce smartphone là le one + 8 pro alors
aujourd'hui je sors deux vidéos puisque
one plus présente deux nouveaux
smartphones oil +8 one + 8 pro je publie
exactement en même temps la vidéo du one
+ 8 et celle du wpt en plus une pro je
vous invite donc à les découvrir la
vidéo du wan plus suivis de si ce n'est
pas déjà fait via le lien qui vous
affichiez juste il si je vous mets
également dans la description de la
vidéo vous allez voir les différences
réellement entre les deux smartphones
c'est intéressant mais en toute chose je
vous ramener quelques mois en arrière où
je vous disais ça si vous regardez un
peu si on prend en photo dans ce qu'on
attend pour toutes les rumeurs dans
toutes les fuites
eh bien ça nous annonce qu'en fait il ya
un truc qui partirait en tout cas pour
un bénéfice qui partiraient ses
bénéfices du très grand écran sans
encoches sans rien puisqu'en trouverez
un petit poisson tous qui me chagrine un
peu à si cette rumeur est avérée
c'est que je trouve qu'avec le one plus
est propre et l'idée les caméras pop up
en plus à faire vrai pas en avant dans
ok on propose un grand écran quad hd
complètement libéré d'encoches de rien
du tout donc en termes de gaming en
terme d'expérience de visionnage de
série de films tout ce que vous voulez
c'est vraiment top et j'aurais du mal à
comprendre que one plus en 2020 revienne
en arrière juste du point de vue
esthétique et force est de constater que
c'est ce qui s'est passé one piece a
donc sorti un nouveau smartphone en
moins de plus huit pros qui a sept
petites caméras planquées dans le
poisson et j'aime moi je vais commencer
par là comme ça on va clarifier la
situation
j'ai moins parce que j'avais beaucoup
l'idée de la caméra pop up qui par
contre a porté un peu plus de poids aux
smartphones à cause du mécanisme qui par
contre ne permettait pas d'avoir une
certification ip68 je comprends que one
+ a fait ce choix là de mettre une
petite caméra de points sont tout
simplement pour pouvoir avoir cette
certification qui fait 68 qui sur les
smartphones très haut de gamme puisque
c'est clairement la donne de ce
smartphone et on va être détaillée dans
cette vidéo dans quelques instants
ils ont fait ce choix là on vient
empiéter un peu sur l'écran au travers
du poinçon et on retient la caméra pop
up j'ai l'impression qu'on va lèvres un
bénéfice par rapport à ce qu'on avait
sur les modèles de l'année dernière où
on avait effectivement un grand écran
complètement dégagé là on a toujours un
grand écran on a plein plein plein de
belles qualités mais voyez ça c'est le
petit point de regret que je peux vous
dire vous donner tout de suite j'attends
vraiment mais j'attends vraiment mais
vous pouvez pas imaginer quelle
impatience des technologies qui nous
permettront de faire disparaître toutes
les caméras que ce soit à l'avant ou
également l'arrière d'ailleurs je puisse
vous a fait attention il ya quelques
mois je vous emmener avec moi à las
vegas hausse
s je vous ai montré une des dernières
technologies de web plus sur lesquels il
travaillait qui leur permettait de
camoufler les caméras que vous aviez à
l'arrière cette techno le toujours pas
implanter t'as plus un test pour voir un
petit peu les règles sont pour prendre
la température j'imagine que ça finira
par arriver très prochainement sur les
smartphones de waele plus en attendant
eh bien ils ont fait soit là pour la
certification je peux pas leur reprocher
je trouve ça un peu moins bien terme
expérience par rapport à cette nouvelle
puce est pro on prend cette page on leur
ferme et maintenant je vais vous
détailler tous les points positifs et
vous dire exactement comment est ce
smartphone et qu'est ce qui peut bien
vous apporter pour je vous rassure quand
même bon il faut vraiment bien et je
suis très pointilleux parce que doit
passer de beaucoup de smartphones et
j'avais trouvé ça vraiment bien mais
rassurez vous si vous voulez acheter ce
smartphone ça vous allait oublier très
rapidement et on est de toute façon en
2020 beaucoup de constructeurs ont fait
ce choix là donc c'est pas déconner
moyens truc qui m'a tout de suite sauté
aux yeux sur ce smartphone autre que sur
la boîte
c'est ça la regarde et android si ça
c'est pas un pied-de-nez à huawei en
disant regardez chez nous vous
attendrons et de chez nous vous avez le
plextor si vous avez toutes les âmes
google je vois pas ce que c'est si vous
voulez savoir ce que vous allez pouvoir
retrouver à l'intérieur a les stocks de
l'écouté de la vidéo du web plus vite
vous verrez c'est exactement la même
chose
on a ici un très beau smartphone avec un
écran bords à bords incurvés que ce soit
sur la face avant
mais également sur le dos ici un cordon
avec l'a5 à l'arrière mais également à
l'avant ce smartphone qui fait 199 g qui
est un peu plus lourd que le one + 8 qui
un capteur d'empreintes digitales qui
déverrouille extrêmement rapidement et
qui existe en 4 couleurs ici moi j'ai
l'onyx blacks c'est un noir brillant il
existe également du glacial green que
j'ai passé un bleu avec un reflet vert
mat il yal ultramarines bleus c'est du
bleu marine voire bleu nuit qui est mat
et j'ai interstellar glossy une édition
spéciale avec du violet qui tient vers
l'orangé un effet miroir j'ai ici un
smartphone qui se prend très très bien
en main qui se glisse très facilement
dans une poche parc on fait attention il
est un petit peu savonnette si vous ne
protégez pas il risque un moment ou un
autre de vous échapper des mains et vous
risquez la bible je vous conseille donc
devenir le protéger et panda protéger
quoi de mieux que les produits de nos
partenaires
in aussi regarder un petit éventail il
ya de quoi faire ici ici sont pas les
produits pour le one plus vite votre
plus huit projets les produits de la
génération de l'année dernière ou à ne
plus être plus cette trompe néanmoins
l'idée reste exactement la mère de
prévenir protéger le dos de votre
smartphone de quoi bien protéger l'écran
de votre smartphone une coque de
protection pour venir protéger le dos de
votre smartphone
mais vous avez également la crh garde
qui vous permettra de garder le dos
visible et devenir le protégé
extrêmement facilement mais surtout ce
qu'il faut savoir c'est que les roumains
de plus huit pros montre ce que one +
sait faire de mieux
et ici on a une opulence de
spécifications techniques
on a ici à d'écran fluide à molette et
une dalle samsung de 6,78 pouces
on a surtout un écran quad hd 3168 par
1440 pixels à 513 pixels par pouce bossi
switcher en eiffage de plus si vous le
souhaitez en 2376 par 1080 pixels mais
surtout vous avez une option à venir
cochet ici qui vous permettra de
switcher entre l'une ou l'autre de
résolution pour éviter décharger la
batterie un ratio 19,8 9e un écran qui
occupent 80 13,6 pour cent de la face
avant
mais ce n'est pas tout puisque vous avez
ici un taux de rafraîchissement de 120
hertz qui va apporter beaucoup de
fluidité
mettez-vous en 120 hertz puisque vos
smartphones dire switcher de façon
intelligente et dynamique en fonction
des applications vous allez utiliser et
ça ça vous apporte beaucoup beaucoup
beaucoup de fluidité lorsque vous allez
venir scrollé joies des jeux c'est
vraiment bien
vous avez une dalle hd air 10 h 10 + au
niveau des couleurs vous pouvez la
mettre soi en vivent sont naturels soit
dire carrément d'avancé en srgb ou en
display p3 personnellement le vif nous
conviendra parfaitement bien et vous
avez aussi un moteur d'amélioration
vidéo vous pouvez venir activer les
effets de couleurs vives pro est
également une atténuation graphique du
déplacement
ça va venir ajouter des images pour
éviter qu'une vidéo qui ne sont pas
tournés en 120 images par seconde que
vous ayez des faits comme ça qui ne soit
pas du tout agréable
on a en plus ici un écran 10 bits ce qui
vous permet d'avoir un milliard de
couleurs un écran qui est certifié
lutter contre la lumière bleue et qui
est 40% plus performants dans ce domaine
là que le modèle de l'année dernière et
une luminosité maximale de 1300 dit
autant vous dire qu'ici entre le 120
hertz entre le qsv plus entre le dimeet
hdr disputé compagnie je vous en passez
vous avez juste une débauche de
spécifications techniques ne serait-ce
qu'au niveau de l'écran mais ça ne
s'arrête pas là puisque la partie audio
n'est pas en reste
des haut-parleurs stéréo un haut parleur
là un deuxième haut parleurs là qui vous
permet d'apporter beaucoup en terme
d'expérience qui notamment grâce à une
bonne spatialisation est autant
d'expériences l'outil mega sur un
smartphone c'est vraiment bien comme
sorbonne +8 vous avez du son dolby atmo
sont dynamiques à venir choisir le
meilleur paramètres pour vous soit en
version film soit version musique et
dans tous les cas ça doit vraiment
amélioré significativement l'expérience
audio 120 smartphones mais ça ne
s'arrête pas là puisque vous avez un
petit micro qui est planqué is it qui
permet ce qu'on appelle lo'jo zoom c'est
un zoom numérique audio directif ça vous
apportera une meilleure expérience audio
lorsque vous allez venir filmer vous
allez être très directif vraiment
chouchoutés ce qu'il y à devant vous
c'est un peu l'idée d'un micro canon
sans l'être également
mais ça ne s'arrête pas là vous avez de
l'audio 3d et si vous voulez écouter
avec un casque puisque vous n'avez pas
de prix d'athlète su vous pouvez prendre
le casque bluetooth avec du bluetooth 5
points et ce smartphone supporte les
codecs à ptx à ptx hdl d à c est assez
autant dire vous avez de quoi faire donc
la partie multimédia grâce à l'écran et
grâce à l'audio est juste top
elle est très bien pour visionner pour
naviguer pour les réseaux sociaux mais
également pour jouer l'expérience audio
est vraiment bien vous savez tout ça
canarde ses canards de la droite ou de
la gauche on arrive chose qui est très
très fluide grâce aux 100 hertz
compte tenu de l'expérience en termes de
guémy elle est vraiment là le gaming est
toujours mis en avant grâce un espace
dédié
vous avez toujours le mode fnatic
pouvait venir active et ça vous permet
de bloquer toutes les notifications et
tous les appels ray simple
l'arrière-plan booster votre jeu et
d'arrêter la carte sim pour améliorer la
connexion réseau
vous utilisez complètement votre machine
pour les meilleures parties et des
meilleures performances graphiques mais
ça ne s'arrête pas là puisqu'en termes
de performance vous avez ce qui se fait
de mieux
vous avez le qualcomm snapdragon 865
vous avez soit 8 soit 12 giga de ram
c'est la lpddr2 5 et vous avez ski c'est
de mieux en terme de stockage c'est lui
fs 3.0 soit 100 réfugiés de stockage
soit 256 dans les deux cas non
extensible vous avez du wifi 6 et vous
avez un smartphone 5 g grâce au modèle x
55 de qualcomm et on obtient le score
coq est sûr en tout 2 577 1869 et si
j'en crois en tout ca me classe à la
première position leur salle de classe
plutôt à la deuxième position puisque
selon mon dernier test le chien aux
mille milices pro est arrivé au dessus
mais tout ça se tient à très très très
peu de choses donc on va en prendre un
smartphone qui est extrêmement fluide
extrêmement rapide j'ai choisi vous
souvenez mais l'année dernière plusieurs
smartphones de one plus occupé la tête
du classement dans tout autant vous dire
que
plus c'est toujours des smartphones
extrêmement performant explique vous
confirmer que le one + 8 pro est un
excellent smartphone très performant et
globalement relativement bien durant
mais ça ça dépend bien évidemment de
vous et de vos usages
jusqu'ici vous avez une batterie de 4510
milliampères heures vous avez bien
évidemment de lanark charge 30 est qu'il
va mettre à leur charge et de 0 à 50 %
en seulement 23 minutes jusqu'à présent
moins de +10 et non pas de recharge sans
fil c'est pas assez rapide s'est passé
parfaitement et là ils ont sorti ça ça
c'est la vague charge 30 sans fil des
mois de plus et une recharge sans fil 30
watts vous avez votre base fondée
reposer votre smartphone vous avez votre
bloc de charge
vous prenez votre smartphone vous le
posez sur 60 de recharge et il va se
charger de 0 à 50 % en seulement 30
minutes maintenir tout cas savoir c'est
que derrière vous avez un petit
ventilateur et qui si vous le mettez à
côté de votre lit le soir pour recharger
peut faire un plaisir à déjouer mais sa
cote est écouté bon ça reste très
discret mais ça ne s'arrête pas là
puisque vous n'avez ci de là à charge un
verset 5 watts
vous avez juste à venir l'activer et
vous pouvez venir recharger tous vos
appareils sans fil très facilement on
peut donc imaginer des écouteurs one + a
chargé son fils la one + vie à rattraper
son retard mais ils le font avec des
techno qui sont rapides donc il le faut
on entre par la grande porte
il s'en retourne sur oxygen os 10 basé
sur un android disent vous avez beaucoup
de possibilités beaucoup d'options
notamment pour venir à personnaliser
votre smartphone vous avait déjà montré
dans nos tests du wan plus vous invite à
les jeter un coup d'oeil comme ça vous
saurez tout on a également une opulence
au niveau de la partie photo vous allez
trouver en haut ici un ultra grand-angle
148 mégapixels qui ouvre à f 2.2 c'est
la sony mx 5 186 qui vous savez si pour
l'ultra grand angle vous sert un capteur
principal sur le wan +8 vous avez un
champ de vision de 119 7 degrés pour
être très précis on our ici à f 2.2 et
cette caméra ultra grand-angle vous sert
également faire de la macro puisque vous
avez un petit moteur intégré à
l'intérieur permettra de faire des
photos en macro jusqu'à 2,5 cm ce qui
veut dire que vous avez si pas un
capteur de 2 mégapixels comme sur le wan
plus vous avez ici un capteur de 48
mégapixels pour venir faire des photos
en macro je vous manque le résultat dans
quelques instants
autant vous le dire dès maintenant c'est
tout autre chose vous avez en dessous
votre caméra principale celle à 48
mégapixels ici on a une sony mx 689 un
objectif qui ouvre à f 1.78 on est à la
stabilisation optique mais également
électronique un pixel qui fait 1,12
micromètres et que vous permettra de
faire des photos en 12 mégapixels grâce
à technologique à pixels en or qui vous
apportera plus de luminosité ici
planqué son côté vous avez un
téléobjectif c'est une caméra de 8
mégapixels tout bref 2.44 une
stabilisation optique un zoom optique x
3,1 zoom numérique x 30
mais si vous regardez en dessous on a
quelque chose de tout nouveau ici c'est
le color fighter caméra c'est une caméra
qui vous servira pour apporter de la
couleur et des effets je vais vous
montrer ça vous avez ici un capteur de 5
mégapixels la caméra ouvre à f 2.4
vous avez bien évidemment votre double
flash led et à l'avant vous avez une
caméra de 5 mégapixels
c'est là sony mx 471 c'est exactement le
même capteur faisait tomber sur le wan
plus vite sauf que cette fois ci on
n'ouvre pas f 2.0
on ouvre à f 2.45 ce un choix
intéressant au café one plus parce que
normalement lorsqu'un constructeur vous
choisi quatre capteurs on a bien
évidemment la combinaison classique
grand angle ultra grand-angle
téléobjectif à c'est ce qu'on trouve un
peu partout mais sur le 4e capteur ce
qu'il vous propose c'est une caméra
tough pour le mode portrait et pour
différentes applications ici vous n'avez
pas ils ont fait le choix de mettre une
caméra qu'il apporte en tout cas des
filtres couleur on voit qu'elle est sûre
il s'adresse aux créateurs aux
photographes en proposant quelque chose
qu'on trouve nulle part ailleurs c'est
donc une proposition de valeur qui est
différente je sais pas si c'est vraiment
ce qui va venir convaincre dans la
majorité en tous cas c'est assez
intéressant pour le relais il faut
savoir également que sordo smartphone
vous propose cinq caméras ici vous en
avez 4 mai réalité vous aurez des cinq
puisque l' ultra grand-angle joue le
rôle de maquereaux donc mieux vaut avoir
un ultra grand-angle avec un petit
moteur intégré qui vous permet de faire
de la macro grâce à la caméra 48e
mégapixels que de la macro année capteur
de 2 mégapixels comme en plus trouver
ailleurs
mais également sur le web + 8 d'un point
de vue logiciel ou un truc est aussi
vraiment bien pensé de la para one plus
je voulais montrer soit 20 de plus suite
mais vous pouvez aussi lire switcher
entre le 12 mégapixels et 48 mégapixels
en appuyant dessus ça s'est très très
bien
sachez quand même que le 12 mégapixels
va permettre capter beaucoup plus de
lumière grâce à techno 4 pixels en un
donc je vous conseille quand même
devenir dessus vous êtes puis sur la
petite rose la plagne vous passez sur l'
ultra grand-angle et vous activez le
mode macro
quand vous êtes là vous pouvez choisir
ici l' ultra grand-angle la caméra
principale et là vous venez zoomer fois
trois optiques et vous pouvez monter
jusqu'en x 30
je vous montrais résultats et photos
dans quelques instants et vous avez une
nouveauté cette fois ci d'un point de
vue logiciel c'est le petit bouton
paramètres et vous avez tous vos
paramètres c'est facile à régler
et si maintenant vous voulez utiliser la
couleur facteurs caméra vous venez
cliquez ici vous avez en tout cinq
possibilités le premier vous n'utilisez
aucune couleur le deuxième
disait des couleurs mates le troisième
une couleur vive le quatrième noir et
blanc est le cinquième photochromes je
vous montre résultats également dans
quelques instants la super stabilisation
marchera ici en 1080p mais également
quatre cas à 30 images par seconde et
uniquement en 30 images par seconde et
si vous venez activer le hdr eh bien
vous ne pouvez pas voir la super
stabilisation puisque le hdr fonctionne
seul capteur principal est la super
stabilisation sur un ultra grand-angle
et comme sur vannes +8 pouvait venir
filmer en 4k signer 30 fps mais
également 60 fps fois donc filmer au
format cinémascope 21/9 et vous avez
bien évidemment du ralenti 720p à 480
images par seconde et 1080p à 240 images
par seconde dès que vous n'alliez pas
caméra tom vous avez quand même le mode
portrait et là dessus nous emmène
intégrée de la reconnaissance d'animaux
pour vos animaux domestiques pour votre
chien pour votre char comme je vous l'aï
dit sur la vidéo du wan +8 je suis
confiné je n'ai pas de chien nietzsche à
la maison je ne peux donc pas le tester
mais sur le principe je le crois sur
parole
voilà les photos faites avec le one + 8
pro si vous n'êtes pas vu mon test du
one puis sachez que j'ai fait exactement
les photos même endroit au même moment
pour pouvoir les comparer et vous allez
voir quelques moines +8 procès quand
même toute chose et ça me paraît
relativement normal vu que ça me des
professionnels alors lorgner sur le
capteur principal
on a eu très très bonne gestion de la
place dynamique on va bien les nuages
derrière rien n'est noir en bas la
couleur au niveau des fleurs et bien
bonne gestion de la lumière bon détail
de tous les côtés ça ce trouve ça
vraiment bien on est légère différence
de saturation sur l' ultra grand-angle
les photos sur les caméras principales
vont être légèrement plus saturés que
sur l' ultra grand-angle
mais ce n'est pas extrêmement flagrant
d'armen une belle préservation de la
colorimétrie donc ça s'est vraiment bien
très bonne gestion également de la plage
dynamique on se rapproche ensuite sur le
zoom x 3 ici on un téléobjectif
le résultat est vraiment bien le x 5
c'est un peu moyen le x 10 n'en parlons
pas et en lal x 39 x là c'est la
débandade de brouille capteur principal
ultra-grand-angle je trouve que one
piece a vraiment fait un bon boulot pour
la gestion des couleurs lorsque vous
allez changer d'objectif
il ya une différence vous arrivez sur le
téléobjectif néanmoins la qualité est
vraiment là on a bien le détail au
niveau des feuilles
les couleurs sont bien la gestion des
lumières est vraiment bonne lorsqu'on se
rapproche en x 10 et bien forcément on
va récupérer du bruit et enfin 30 voilà
c'est pas ouf caméra principale ultra
quand on voit bien différent de
saturation a sur ses feuilles vertes 1 x
3 x 10 et x 30 thème est la principale
ultra-grand-angle les photos du x 10
sont pas ouf par rapport à ceux trouvés
sur d'autres smartphones ici on récupère
quand même pas mal de bruit et ensuite
le x 30 bon voilà c'est pour avoir un
peu laissé whaou mais au-delà de ça pas
grand chose caméra principale est ultra
grand-angle
alors vous avez 10 $ et la vidéo test du
wan +8 devenir comparer cette photo du
trac en temps à la même photo prise
exactement au même endroit au même
moment avec le moins de +8 et on voit
qu'ici on aime bien meilleure gestion
soit modèles professionnels au niveau de
la place dynamique on se rapproche
ensuite avec le faux 10 et sur le x 30
fait les mêmes réflexions et là on
arrive en mode macro alors là la macro
c'est vraiment autre chose pourquoi
parce qu'on n'est pas sur un capteur de
2 mégapixels ou les capteurs de 48
mégapixels là pour le coup de la macro
deviens vraiment intéressante vous voyez
bien ici les détails
la qualité est vraiment meilleure par
rapport à l'autre ont lâché un peu loupé
ça c'est ma faute
on a vraiment beaucoup plus de détails
c'est vraiment beaucoup plus beaux et à
sur cette photo tout de suite c'est
beaucoup mieux
on a des couleurs qui sont beaucoup plus
pétantes on a beaucoup plus de détails
et c'est vraiment vraiment vraiment
josiane et je vous laisse apprécier je
me rapproche même sur des roses comme ça
c'est vraiment bien bonne gestion de la
lumière aussi on a beaucoup plus de
détails
la difficulté maintenant ce sera vous
passez à la bonne distance pour sortir
des belles photos au niveau de la macro
mais dans l'ensemble le mans là dessus
la macro sert à quelque chose
la caméra de celle fils fait aussi un
bon boulot le mode portrait est pas mal
mais pas complètement ouf sur la caméra
principale et sur l' ultra grand-angle
ça va mon un problème ici au niveau de
la gestion des hautes lumières qu'on
retrouve sur mon front et ici aussi au
niveau de la main mais le détourage dans
l'ensemble est quand même plutôt bons on
m'a dit 'maintenant résultats de cette
nouvelle caméra color ce nouveau capteur
ça c'est la première photo qui est prise
avec cette caméra la naissance
absolument aucun filtre bon somme toute
assez classique ça marche on va
appliquer le tout premier film moi
j'aime bien ce filtre ce côté un petit
peu vintage
on va continuer qu'à côté ville qui va
vraiment venir saturé why not
le noir et blanc si on veut et ça tout
de suite c'est un peu plus bizarre mais
bon faire des effets pourquoi pas voilà
les conditions dans lesquelles j'ai
filmé au niveau de la photo de nuit j'ai
filmé avec mon gh5 je n'ai absolument
aucune colorimétrie aucun lot c'est flat
deux chefs là que vous vous rendez bien
compte qu'on ne va globalement pas grand
chose et voilà le résultat avec le web
plus fluide trop mais bon voilà moi ça
m'épate pas des masses trouve que le
rendu est pas génial on voit qu'il ya
beaucoup de bruit c'est normal c'est la
nuit une deuxième photo prise avec les
mêmes capteurs voilà ça ne transcende
pas l'ultra grand-angle ajoute beaucoup
de mousse est meilleur que ça vole tout
de suite mais c'est pas dingue je prends
des photos maintenant de l'autre côté il
ya beaucoup de bruit pour moi la
photonique ce sont les ultra grand-angle
ou sur la caméra principale
eh bien je dirais que ce n'est pas
satisfaisant rembourse la dragonne 1865
12 giga de ram un écran 120 hertz un
milliard de couleurs haut parleurs
stéréo
je crois qu'en termes d'expérience de
gaming on est là dessus vraiment ce qui
va bien et quand je vous parle de gaming
c'est toujours utile à tort le plus
exigeant donc ça veut dire que tous les
autres usages que vous allez avoir en
termes de visionnage de série 2
multimédia quant aux réseaux sociaux
vous avez une expérience qui est
vraiment très très bonne et on voit que
sur le moins de plus huit pros on a une
opulence de spécifications
technologiques one + a été loin là
dessus je trouve en tout cas ça plutôt
intéressant c'est un smartphone en plus
qui pour la première fois est certifié
ip 68 résistants à l'eau et à la
poussière
l'huile et le web + 8 ne l'est pas vous
pouvez avoir une double carte sim ici
pas d'extension grâce à une carte
microsd ça ce n'est pas possible
il a bien évidemment du nfc et ça se
voit que vous peut trouver en deux
configurations 8 +128 au tarif de jeu
voulu tout de suite
899 euros en onyx black et vous avez la
config 12 plus 256 en glace et grill à
999 euros c'est à dire car un euro près
vous êtes à 1000 euros
il ya une vraie augmentation de prix
scellier notamment ont fait d'avoir
cette opulence technologique est
également liée au fait d'avoir la 5g qui
va forcément augmenter les prix des
smartphone à smartphone dispo à partir
du 21 avril prochain je vous mettrai les
liens bien évidemment en bas dans la
description par rapport au moins de +7
problème dernières ont donc on a une
augmentation significative du prix sur
la plus grosse version mais il ya aussi
un côté positif du fait d'avoir ce
nouveau modèle c'est que le web + 7 pro
et devrait de plus être diminuée en
tarif ça reste des smartphones très
actuel très performant donc si vous
voulez aller chez one plus et que vous
ne voulez pas mettre quasiment 1000
euros dans un smartphone vous pouvez
aller sur les voies de cette fois de
plus cette pro qui sont aussi des très
bons produits
on peut donc se poser la question
pourquoi est ce que one plus à 1000 la
5g dans ce smartphone puisque au final
ça vient augmenter le prix et bien tout
simplement parce que là dessus on a un
lancement global un lancement
international avec deux produits et pas
des déclinaisons 4g et 5g comme peut le
faire notamment samsung sol sont ultra
où il ya qu un modèle 5 gb soit autres
n'allez version 4g et 5g non naturelle
plus pas fait le choix de mettre
uniquement en voie de +8 owen plus huit
pros pour tous les pays
il ya des marchés très fort pour un plus
pour la 5g les états unis la chine
l'inde en europe il y à la suisse il y à
la phalange qui ont la 5g comme la 5g
doit arriver normalement en 2020 et il
va se déployer en 2021
ce qui en tout cas le calendrier
attendue et annoncée et bien votre
smartphone sera d
et pour la 5g et comme vous n'allez pas
changé en 2020 heures ou 2022 eh bien
vous aurez la 5g lorsque la 5g sera
quasiment déployés partout
c'est un peu l'idée et la stratégie
derrière tout ça donc la question qui se
pose c'est est-ce qu'il faut acheter
aujourd'hui un smartphone 5 g oui ou non
mais ça je me sens pas dans une
prochaine vidéo dont je vous invite à
vous abonner aujourd'hui ce n'est pas
déjà le cas en tout cas ce tant que
besoin de plus a fait du bon boulot sur
ce smartphone là il ya une vraie
débauche technologique on a un très bon
produit qui est adaptée a beaucoup d'
usage certes le tarif est assez élevé
par rapport à ce qu'on avait avant
mais si on regarde à la concurrence à
technologie identique ou sensiblement
identique
et bien c'est très cohérent a vous de me
dire maintenant vous ce que vous en
pensez en bas en commentaire
en tout cas je suis convaincue et qu'en
est il pour vous sur ce je vous embrasse
donne rendez vous dès demain parce qu'on
va continuer à parler tech il ya plein
de belles choses qui arrivent croyez moi
à bientôt ciao
[Musique]